hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast from heart to mind
simplified IPS cell reprogramming into
cardiac and neural cells under hypoxic
conditions presented by dr. Rick Cohen
we are excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by eppendorf
eppendorf is a leading life science
company that develops instruments
consumables and services for liquid
sample and cell handling in laboratories
worldwide its product range includes
pipettes centrifuges mixers
spectrometers and PCR cyclers as well as
freezer bioreactors co2 incubators
shakers cell culture consumables and
cell manipulation systems eppendorf
products are broadly used in academic
and industrial research laboratories
worldwide I'm Kristina jewel elaborate
shinobi or moderator for today's event
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen will answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge that window just
click on the screen icon located in the
lower right now if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of the presentation window
or you can use the Q&A button to let us
know you're having a problem this is an
educational webinar and this offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the c/e
button located at the bottom left hand
corner of your web page and follow the
process of obtaining your credits also
throughout this presentation you will
notice a few pools that will pop up in
the middle of your screen you will have
30 seconds to respond and we appreciate
your participation I would now like to
introduce our speaker dr. Rick Cohen dr.
is the director of the stem cell
training course and research associate
in the department of biomedical
engineering at rutgers university over
the past eight years he has been
instrumental in providing cell based
materials and hands-on training to
participants from both academia and
industry in the past he directed the
Rutgers stem cell core facility and has
trained at the first generation of t32
multi-institutional stem cell trainees
he is collaborated with pepperjack in
rocky hill new jersey to develop several
hit commercialized stem cell media and
related products he plans to continuous
efforts to offer engineered cellular
solutions to answer questions about
cellular reprogramming and
differentiation to needed cell types one
of the ongoing projects and dr. Cohen's
lab examines its dopaminergic neuron and
cardiogenic direct differentiation of
ipscs be optimized using small molecules
the game of the study is to determine
the optimized and scalable method to
produce functional dopaminergic neurons
for studies and Parkinson's disease the
final focus of this project is to seed
the cardiomyocyte or their progenitor on
a biocompatible and transplantable
scaffold in order to create a cardiac
patch capable of restoring function to
damage myocardium for dr cohn's complete
bio please elaborate scom please join me
in welcoming dr. Rick Cohen I will now
turn the presentation over to him dr.
Cohen thank you for that introduction
and welcome to the presentation this
morning I'm going to start off with poll
question number one you currently
reprogram cell
we'll get underway with the presentation
today's presentation is separated into
three sections the first of which will
start right away with the generation of
human IPS d with one transfection before
we get into the full presentation here's
a small introduction about human induced
pluripotent stem cell they can be
generated by introducing certain factors
namely opt for socks to ALS and ce mec
in our protocols we've changed simic to
L Mick with our polycistronic vector
which I'll introduce a little bit later
we have some other genes that will help
us both select and view the cells that
are undergoing this week programming
typically when these cells get
reprogrammed they can be induced to form
both ectoderm endoderm and mesoderm in
today's talk we're going to focus on
neural cells specifically dopaminergic
neuron and cardiac muscle lastly if
these cells can be generated in a way
without using animal products in a safe
way that they have been shown to
differentiate and not form tumors
potentially these cells can be used for
patient specific cellular therapy some
of the factors to optimize involve gene
delivery method you want to transfer
single multiple plasmid use chemical or
electroporation method what kind of cell
type do you want to start off with
either a newly established primary
cultures or something that's commercial
or even transformed things like culture
medium containing either serum or
defined that are serum-free are
important to consider and lastly we have
gone from a standard co2 regulated
incubator too low to which means the
levels of oxygen are regulated by
pumping in
nitrogen so generating iPSCs with one
transfection optimizing the
reprogramming here we're going to
introduce a novel plasmid so this is a
polycistronic episomal plasmid together
with the latest iteration which contains
the maya d trans activating domain and
that's called the tad domain fused to
the five prime end of octave or and ox4
is strung together with the other gene
using a self-splicing domain called a to
a domain originally derived from the
foot-and-mouth disease virus that is
found in other types of virus we have
included blast aside and SD a manase
gene fused together with a monomer of
red fluorescent protein to be able to
both select and visualize the last thing
to consider if you're going to use DNA
is that your DNA must be what i call
ultra-low endotoxin so if you have a kit
a commercially available kit that claims
to have super endotoxin levels we take
that kit and during an intermediate step
use triton x 114 to further reduced
endotoxin level without that additional
step we find that there's too much
endotoxin and we don't get good
reprogramming and this is the depiction
of the episomal plasmid it contains the
or EP and the eb and a motif which are
typical to pretty much all episomal
plasmid system we've optimized by
including a small PG k promoter upstream
from the ebna1 but the main cassette is
promoted using a CAG promoter this is a
CMV chick beta-actin fusion which
robustly expresses the tad opt for socks
to say LF L mick and rfp blast followed
by a WP re domain and a beta globin poly
a
upon Trent transfection into the cell
this is translated to RNA within the
cell and then made into four separate
protein where you have the to a domain
in this area it's thought to cause a
ribosome to skip and thus make five
sucker protein whole question number two
what method of reprogramming do you use
in your laboratory and you'll have a few
seconds to answer this question before
we go on
let's proceed again generation of ipscs
with one transection we're on to point
number two cell culture optimization low
02 tension using a four percent oxygen
has allowed us to use this single
episode and have very successful
reprogramming when we use standard
oxygen nor moxie which is around
nineteen to twenty percent we got very
little transformation when generating
fibroblast we also use human serum not
because the human serum works any better
than fetal bovine serum it's because we
want to take our research to a
translational type of situation so that
we use all humanized condition opposed
to standard media that uses 2.5 million
molar glutamine three or four times as
much is needed for robust fibroblast
growth another point is pretreatment
with the p53 inhibitor and more recently
we're now including a cash-based 3
inhibitor does two things one it
inhibits p53 and if you look at other
tips from commercially available sources
they include a separate plasmid or a
combination plasmid to interfere with
p53 signaling so here we rely on a small
molecule and the caspase-3 inhibitor
helps with viability post
electroporation and we only include that
for a few days the other thing we do is
we've switched away from using matrix L
which is an animal drive product which
works perfectly fine nothing is wrong
with nature gel but we use recombinant
vite renekton also produced in an animal
tree or a xeno free situation so not
only do we grow the fiberglass on beat
renekton but then when we do the
electroporation there immediately plated
and generated into IPS cells on that
substrate
and here's a depiction of our protocol
the electro / 8 using a neon system from
thermo Fisher using the 100 micro litre
tip side typically we use 10 micrograms
of DNA with a million cells you've got
on to now use upwards of 5 million cell
with the same amount of DNA and see
almost equally good transfection we
haven't finished those testing to see if
we get equally good generation of IPS
cells but I'm assuming because the
viability and the red fluorescence are
equally as well we can scale up the
amount of cells that's day zero they are
electroporated and then played it in the
same fiber blast media they've been
growing in together with five small
molecules the next day we change the
medium to a knockout serum replacer this
is kos r supplement also from thermo
fisher using a low osmolarity medium or
knockout GMM type of medium again with
five small molecules we now add back pen
strep which we've omitted in the first
case and go to this election with five
to ten micrograms of male of last
assignment for up to a week usually
between 10 and 14 days we observe
something called a proto colony and in
the following slides I'll show you what
that looks like essentially that's a
rearrangement of the standard patterns
the fiberglass grow into into something
else it's hard to describe other line
the last step is after 21 days where we
start to see these more mature Colleen
and this may take even up to 30 days we
manually clean away the non transform
fiberglass we use
PBS EDG a packaging method so no enzymes
use aside from when we passage the fiber
blast over here so we go from enzymes to
non-enzymatic methane we also change to
an animal free media which is human
serum albumin containing or non human
serum albumin containing again we
generally get better performance using
it with albumin at least for the first
part and they're still plated on be
connected only passage done the last
part as I mentioned before five small
molecules some of these are commercially
available as a kit called boost or boost
to bmv millipore here's our p53
inhibitor and because i have a
publication in process I can't name the
dot 1l inhibitor but there are several
and this is crucial without the dot 1l
inhibitor the efficiency of the
epidermal reprogramming is quite poor in
fact sometimes we don't get Colin
survived the addition of this last into
the five small molecule we get anywhere
between 5 and 25 clones in one well of a
6-well dish when we start out with at
least a half a million cells played it
in that format poor question number
three do you already use a low oxygen
tension incubator routine stem cell
cultures and if yes what percentage of 0
to do you use for reprogramming yourself
I'll give you a few seconds to answer
this and then we'll progress on to the
rest of the presentation
so if you're interested in a more
inclusive and expressive study there's
another application note that I worked
on with eppendorf I've seen in this
slide and the incubator that I use in my
lab is similar to the 170 are with the
for split door the one that i have is
slightly different it's actually an aged
split so these doors are split into a
compartment that actually helps a lot
with the minimization of loss of
nitrogen and fluctuations of the levels
of oxygen and co2 so using the neon
system this is one day post
electroporation this is the phase
contrast and as you can see many cells
get the rfp there are some that don't
and what I refer to as a proto colony
and this may be a little difficult to
see is depicted in this green box now
also in red where the pattern of the
swirl of the fiber blaster changed into
this area that looks like something
different is going on and when you
follow these after about twenty one days
they appear to be somewhat normal
looking IPS colonies and sometimes you
get overgrowth when you take these 21
days and you clean them and passage them
using the PBS EDTA method you get
carryover of the feeder cells which are
the same fiberglass there all along here
that either did not receive the RFP or
if they did receive the RFP or the
polycistronic episomal vector they
didn't reprogram for one reason or
another
clearly this is quite large very
well-defined border still it takes three
to four passages to eliminate the
carryover feeder layers and the way we
do that is by using the pdf's method
again we allow the cells clumps to
settle out and the single cells seem to
float and by successive washes you rinse
away in a single cell and retain the
clumps so it's a very straightforward
very easy method to use these are the
same cells one day post-split and they
already forming well-defined colonies
they look much cleaner and four days
later they're expanding and then this is
changed from the animal free to
something called the animal free low
protein media which is the same recipe
minus the human serum albumin so we've
gone from serum containing fiber blast
media to Kozar which is a serum product
and that is animal containing you can
get a human version of the Knockouts
term replacer which we have not yet
tried and then you can go to the low
protein media eventually to continually
culture yourself we do some
immunological characterization which is
typical to qualitatively describe what's
going on to the cells and here in the
top left is Daffy just a regular nuclear
died Lynn 28 and nanog are also
pluripotency gene which have been
described in the so-called Thompson mix
that combines ox4 stocks to nanog and
then 28 for reprogramming in our studies
we use klf4 and l neck so the presence
or appearance of Lynn 28 and man on is
not from our plasmid it is from the
reprogramming process the link 28 is a
cytoplasmic rna-binding protein and
nanog is a nuclear transcription factor
and furthermore the appearance of trial
60 the bottom left indicates that these
are also IPS cells so in combination
these are three markers that proved our
point when we use flow cytometry so this
is another immunised dating protocol use
it these cells are grown on vitra neck
then and again this is the animal free
low protein media no HS a similar media
with HSA and we double stain for SSC a4
and that's like trial 160 it's a cell
surface marker and we Costain that with
Lin 28 these ourselves are dissociated
off the plate and in this case when we
do that type of analysis we use at UK's
you can also use triple you do not use
PDF CDTA because those leave behind a
lot of doublet so when those cells are
coasting under both condition you see
around ninety eight percent it's a very
high degree of purity for these cultures
whole question number four which
lineages do you try to optimize the
differentiation protocol for in your lab
I'll give you a few questions a few
seconds to answer this question before
we proceed with the presentation
alright thanks let's go on to the next
slide now we're going to proceed to the
second part the differentiation of these
ipscs into Delta the nerd doctor on the
differentiation into dopaminergic
neurons we've decided to work with
another group that has collaborated with
us and petrotech and use the small
molecule base combination to Alcon
hitters active in like kinase is this is
the tgf-beta pathway SPAD pathway so two
inhibitors there a gsk-3 data inhibitor
and also the combination with sonic
hedgehog signaling instead of using
sonic hedgehog which when you buy it in
a recombinant form is often not modified
properly to be robust and signaling but
small molecules will directly activate
the pathway by bypassing and activating
smoothened and this is based on the work
of stenner code at all this is a group
in Germany and they pioneered this and
now we're optimizing it and changing it
slightly to allow the user to have more
flexibility we are using a media from
pepper Tech which is like a DMF 12
combined with a neuro basil there's an n
to be 27 mix added which is animal free
at this point with also l-ascorbic acid
its combined with these alcon hitters
LDN 193 189 and the SB 4315 42 compound
again with a smooth and agonist and the
GSK 3 beta inhibitor here is chir 90 90
to 1 that compound is going to be
featured later when we do the cardiac
differentiation as well you may see
other abbreviations be
bdnf g4g B&F c4c dnf a for active in a
key for tgf-beta three and eight for
fgf8 we call this den small molecule
based protocol and as we go through the
timeline you'll see the different days
of differentiation or development the
first one is called SP anyone which
stands for floor play neural epithelial
cell page one and this will take place
within four or five days we call that
the neuro sphere formation originally we
were using a specialized dish that's
treated with a polymer to prevent the
attachment of the cell however we've
gone on map to use the non TC treated
eppendorf 6 well dish which is about the
same price as a TC dish much cheaper
than a polymer coated ish and we get
similar result so we're pretty happy
with that finding once we develop these
neurospheres and I'll show you pictures
of those the next slide we plate those
we call those the adherent expansion
things or the FPE Tuesday that goes on
for another four days after which we get
to the FPA three intermediate stopping
stage and this means they need to be
expanded for at least four to five
passages we use a cute a's at first and
then go on to the PBS EDTA method and
i'll explain why but this floor plate
stage can be used to develop not only
dopaminergic neurons but other type of
neurons so does not specify the midbrain
specifically when we're done
with the floorplate we freeze down ten
fifteen twenty even thirty ampules of
cells and store them away we go on to
the patterning stage which removes the
two inhibitors so now we're limited to
the smooth antagonist and chir in this
stage we call that the den one and two
the difference is then one when we
replayed them we include rock inhibitor
to help them stick and survive the band
to just has these two compounds right
here smooth am I going to ghir then we
go to something called the damn three-
going to forward this so you see the
damn speed plus the damn three- is based
on the ban three plus however we remove
the dye butyral cyclic AMP E and the D
apt which is a gamma secretase
inhibitors which eventually inhibits not
signaling so in this context where we
add cdns and fgf8 we discovered a novel
phase which we call dan three- so we're
able to robustly expand and amplify the
number of incoming cells that have
dopaminergic quality we see expression
of th early without having to go to the
damn three terminal differentiation and
here are some pictures of what the cell
should look like when you have done it
correctly so this is the FT anyone stage
and what you would expect our
neurospheres but really what happens
under this context we see a sausage or
elongation type situation and if we
manually select limited numbers we plate
these out more or less we do two things
selection small-scale in a 24-well dish
and then bulk intense
in addition when you do it right you see
patches that almost resemble IPS patches
but they're different morphologically
different now we've progressed to the
FPE three-stage and cleaned up some of
the cells that are forming more
differentiated cells when we have a
culture of f pg3 where we both feed them
quite as much as we should you still get
these patches and it may be hard to see
but there are cells in these areas
there's very few Daffy positive cells
which indicates cell nuclei but the
floor plate staying with Grail and Fox a
22 canonical markers for floor plate so
we're able to make really good floor
plates of small molecules then when you
go on to amplify and then switch them
into the FPS the bill 23 or the damn
three situation rather again here's
nuclei and this is 500 micron the scale
scale bar here's 500 microns we see
expression of synapsin it's cold
alkalizing with tyrosine hydroxylase and
this is marker of mature neuron we also
see early on the appearance of pi/2 x3
which is a definitive marker in
combination with tyrosine hydroxylase
and tuj one for immature or committed
but not fully differentiated
dopaminergic neuron this method is quite
good at generating the cell in the
literature there's a PA 6 feeder layer
based amount of studies where they take
this mouse cranial mesenchymal stem cell
and use it as a feeder layer for neural
cells and you get robust dopaminergic
differentiation why that happened they
don't know so several studies they use
proteomics results and distill down half
a dozen to a dozen different growth
factors as a more defined method and why
the ph 6 feet
layer works we try to use only those
growth factors but we found we had to
use a few small molecule the typical
neural izing one to at least start to
cascade for this growth factor-beta
timeline similar to what you saw with
the FPE this is EC 23 stable retinoic
acid analog so you can use retinoic acid
but be aware it's both thermo sensitive
and light sensitive h4h GF Patos a
growth factor sdf-1 alpha vegf d4 vvs1
is soluble frizzled receptor one
frizzled receptor protein 1 it finds
wince and neutralizes them p for pi otro
fin and I 24 igf2 in this context we
continue to use the pepper bro neural
stem cell media and again very similar
to the other pathway where we have a
stage called dopa one where we generate
these neurospheres go on to an adherent
expansion patterning and what happens in
this stage some of the neurospheres when
we play them out are certainly not of
neural differentiation quality and then
sometimes we have to do a little bit of
manual cleaning sometimes more packaging
methods and lastly when you go to the
dope of three stage it's similar as a
damn three stage where we include bdnf
gdf dibutyl cyclic and P and D apt we do
now include active in a and tgf-beta as
we do find it does hasten the
differentiation but what's interesting
dope tattoo stage when we include C D
and F and fgf8 we get these robust very
very small sub 10 micron cell
that respond only cdns and we think
those are our novel dopaminergic
precursor let's go to see what these
cells look like opposed to the sausage
leg cells that you see the Dan Delta one
these are all circulated so this is
retinoic acid and sonic hedgehog and
they should be hollow and small if you
let them get too big let's start to get
very dark and necrotic in the middle do
not let that happen when you plate these
out the sphere stick and rapidly spread
out and lastly slightly higher
magnification you can see that these
cells appear to be very bipolar and long
ramified processing these are typical
neural looking cells you don't know if
they're glial or neuronal and that's
where the recipe the dopa to recipe
helps us expand and this is
immunological characterization of those
cultures so you can see robust synapsin
and cold vocalization with tyrosine
hydroxylase and lastly i had mentioned
the use of fgf8 and CDNs to amplify this
progenitor pool this has become very
important because fgf8 is known to
affect dopaminergic cell growth but
there's less known about cdf and no one
knows why or no one knows how C D and F
work so we're using this system kind of
characterize the effect of PDMS on the
cell
here's an example of what happened so
when you played out the cells from the
Delta to stage you let them get buried n
so this is a mat of cell there's and
we've calculated somewhere around three
million cells in one well the six well
dish these are not hold these are small
colony and by the addition of a DNS
alone it looks like there's less cells
but all of these patches are highly
three-dimensional and we get somewhere
between seventy percent on a hundred
percent more so in one well so we get
around five to six million cells as
opposed to the untreated so clearly gdnf
has an effect but we don't know exactly
what it's doing for these cells
functional great we've grown these cells
up we can amplify them two different
ways but do they actually do something
useful so i'm going to show you data
called hplc and we're going to look at
building secretion and what I'm not
going to show you today which is ongoing
there's a collaboration with dr.
products mogy and a postdoc Nicola
Francis where she's going to take both
the dopa three and then three cells so
from both methods and transplant them
into animal models of protestant disease
using a special matrix you're not
familiar with hplc the data is kind of
old timey looking it's a trait that
comes out it looks like little peak and
this is a standard mix so the lab that
has the hplc will put together 25 p como
lo of norepinephrine dopamine go pack
which is mana mean
today's broken down from dopamine okay
so dopac lead or it's from dopamine and
then finally homo vanilla acid derived
that 5-ht is serotonin leads to 5h I a a
and if you're interested in the main 5
hydroxy indole acetic acid so those are
run and then a sample is injected and if
it's dopamine it lines up with this peak
if it's north enough friend it will show
up here and so it's based on where the
peaks and how high the peaks are so when
we do the studies here a transmitter
release using cells derived from the
dopa protocol or the Dan protocol and
this is when we change the media we do a
washout just by adding tanks balanced
salt solution we're creating a stimulus
and they're secreting dopamine and then
when you add calcium chloride you get a
depolarization we get further release
what we're trying to do now is figure
out a way where we could change into a
base media with no other compounds that
would interfere with our hplc without
eliciting a change in secretion of
dopamine so both are seeing here and
then more recently we've seen a
secretion of serotonin in cells that
were prepared using the damn method not
as much scene with the dopa method we
don't know what the difference is but at
least now we can tell that maybe we have
something else aside from dopaminergic
cells in our culture last part of the
talk is going to introduce the
differentiation into the cardiomyocyte
this is separated into three ideas here
small molecule base and this is a very
simple straightforward plate the cells
out change the media a few different
times and if you do a right you start
getting part of my sites within 10 days
we try to optimize the use of human
serum albumin we've determined you can
use some amount of human serum and or a
defined mix of be 27 while this seems to
be consistent and we call this the
14-day protocol because nothing really
changes you just have to wait you're
interested to know if we can migrate to
some fantasy type of situation where we
could make cardiovascular progenitors
and then use those for scalability
purposes and use those and see those on
to these biocompatible matrices so right
now I'm going to show you some data
using this simple cardiac
differentiation and we call this the
14-day protocol the base media here it's
rpmi 500 micrograms per ml of HSA then
use the same type of dilution or a one
to two hundred dilution of human serum
and get similar results and with quite
high amount of ass korvac acid you take
your stem cells your IPS cells and use a
cute a's place them with rock inhibitor
on be tracked in and wait about a week
they form almost the mono layer you
switch it into the RPM I media
containing a high dose of the CI hir
gsk-3 beta inhibitor for two days very
high dose for two days you remove it and
that goes back just to the base media
for two days and then two more
additional days with the wint inhibitor
it's actually a porcupine inhibitor and
enzyme that modifies wind and allow
for secretion and we use here wind 59 c
WP 2 or 1 or for those work as well and
then by day 8 we've seen beating of
cellular clusters so if you go back here
to the phase contrast you can see that
there's these clusters and some of them
are smaller some of them are larger and
it's kind of stochastic we can't really
program the shape of the cluster least
thing for data for a nuclear
transcription factor alpha smooth muscle
actin which is in both cardiac and
smooth muscle and a cardiac specific
name for cardio 10 so together with
these three antibodies we're sure we're
making cardiomyocyte you don't yet know
if they're ventricular in origin or
atrial but will characterize that a
little bit later on every once in a
while we see in culture these clusters
and this one happened to resemble what
we call the beating bunny and I'm going
to play a movie and you'll see the movie
takes about a minute and you'll see the
clusters be and that's a representation
of what we see with this protocol
you
okay and we're back so you had an
example of what happens with this
cluster and if you are paying attention
you would see a lot of the clusters in
this rabbit well here here all over
we're beating some of the other areas
around here we're beating as well so if
we can get these cells on a
biocompatible physically able to move
matrix and create something consistent
then we could create this cardiac catch
so that's why in the next protocol where
we call this thing a a two-step cardiac
differentiation protocol is to make
these cardiovascular progenitor cells
where we can optimize the production of
both cardiomyocytes and the much-needed
vasculature that would help the self
integrate into a real heart tissue so
very much like the 14-day protocol
accutane a template the cells but we
don't let them expand in stem cell media
rather we go directly from stem cell
media into dmm b27 with insulin I did
forget to mention up front to the 14-day
protocol until the cells are beating no
insulin is added there are two genes
that are important to keep suppress and
if you add insulin you get those genes
expressed and you get milk cardiomyocyte
but since we're making cardiovascular
shutters here we add insulin by a
glycerol a lower amount of laa also chir
so we're activating when pathways and
also bmp4 we call this message dermal
induction so the cells from this can be
taken to other pathways not only
cardiomyocyte for generators and then
after these cells get then we package
them for at least three to four times
into a similar media but now include two
hibbett earth dorsal morphin and 8301
and we use beta mercaptoethanol as an
antioxidant and these former mono layer
and in Serie A these are forming these
cardiovascular progenitor cells which
would the second phase would be taking
those and adding the same whyn't
inhibitor along with bmp4 and induced
cardiomyocyte so we're at this stage and
hopefully by next year we'll have some
good results with the cardiomyocyte
generators and this pathway so I can't
answer that yet but hopefully like I
said in a few months we'll we'll get
some answer the poll question number
five if you use low 02 what are the
benefits you find with your culture and
you'll have a few seconds to answer them
before we finish up
so in summary we're able to generate
iPSCs with one single transfection that
we do use electroporation it is very
simple if you have a chemical
transfection you can try that simplified
protocol it does require small molecule
I've shown you we're able to take those
cells and differentiate them to
different ways they're related but
they're definitely two different ways to
make dopaminergic cells we're in the
process of characterizing the action
potential and very much more excitingly
from my perspective what is cdns doing
to these cells so we're doing some
immunostaining to see if they're
increasing the proliferation rate the
differentiation rates and if we get more
dopaminergic cells or just more neurons
in general and what will happen to these
cells in vivo and I'm excited to
collaborate with dr. Millgate group and
follow the transplantation of the cells
from these both pathways into knobs give
mice after they receive
6-hydroxydopamine lesion so can they
repair parkinsonian symptoms lastly is
differentiation into cardiomyocytes the
first 14-day protocol is simple and
straightforward somewhat stochastic we
can't predict what are the shape of
those clumps that's why we're going to
the second type of protocol and
determine if the cells we're getting our
atrial ventricular apparently if you
include low dose of retinoic acid during
the initial stages very much like the
dopa protocol you get more atrial origin
to get those cells the collaboration
with dr cohn's group the Rutgers
biomaterial will allow us to create a
patch and first we put them in a 24-well
dish and then scale up to a 6-well dish
and see if we can create a beating patch
and some of these biomaterials are
durable and some will degrade over time
one month six months one year lastly
another collaboration with dr. perfumes
lab and biomedical engineering is using
a fusion of elastin like protein with
different growth factors that form
nanoparticles that will hasten the
vascular ization of these transplantable
biomaterials i'd like to thank you for
your attention and these are some of the
collaborators and the people that are
supporting and the institutions that are
supporting two studies pepper Tech and I
have been working together for several
years to develop media specifically
animal Frears no.3 the standard Kurtz
lab was supported by Michael J Fox and
these are studies that were pioneered by
dr. Peter Reinhart and he's no longer
there he's at this Institute and Nicole
Francis and she was supported by NIH
grant she performed the hplc to
transplantation is probably going to do
the action potential and these are some
undergraduate hasta and she's part of
the women in STEM program at Rutgers and
Neil who's also he'll be any student and
they were responsible for doing the cell
cultures both the neuron and the
cardiomyocyte I'd like you to thank you
for your attention and if you do want to
know more about the incubators there's a
whole landing page and there's not only
these larger sized incubators but
there's some smaller size versions that
they're not quite boutique but they are
I guess the 48 litre instead of 170
leader thank you again
and I'm going to turn over the
presentation to our moderator if you
have any questions please push those out
as soon as you can thank you dr. Cohen
for that informative presentation as you
mentioned it is time for Q&A and I want
to remind our audience if you have a
question you'd like to ask dr. Cohen
please do so now just click on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click assign button we will answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for okay let's get started dr.
Cohen our first question is why do you
think hypoxia is important for
reprogramming why has to do with certain
pathways that we've not completely
characterized that are either not turned
off or turned on in lower oxygen tension
its differentiation carried out under
hypoxic conditions yes all the studies
that you've seen today we use low co2
concentration at four percent we don't
know if that's optimal for neuron and
cardiomyocyte but we started off with
that and we're going to investigate
other levels in the near future can we
adapt our protocols to use low oxygen
tension absolutely just go ahead and
lure it immediately you can try an
intermediate or just go right to four
percent how do i remove the pizzle
vector subsequently from myself again so
the episomal vector is very inefficient
and doesn't persist so if you look at
the red fluorescence you'll see it fade
over the course of 21 to 30 days it's
well known that it loses five percent or
more efficiency every time the cell
divided so while
there's no real proof in this study that
the DNA doesn't somehow we combine into
the cells we no longer see red
fluorescent and thus as other people
have said the episome vector is
inefficient and gets lost after time dr.
Cohen for the two-step cardiac
differentiation protocol at which step
do you add insulin in your medium so the
first step making the mental dermal
cells you would have insulin and then
when you amplify and grow them as the cv
pcs or the cardiovascular progenitor
cells you still have it and only when
you go to the wint signaling inhibition
step do you remove it halfway oh go
ahead sorry I dedicate that there's very
few studies to show that the CV pcs
really exists go ahead okay we have an
audience member who would like to
inquire about what method do you use for
freezing cells so I published a protocol
paper in conjunction with bios vision
and we detail that whole method and it's
very simple we passage with PBS EDTA and
we don't even centrifuge the cell so we
remove a PDS ETA when the sales round up
we gently squirt the cells off and put
them in a tube and for example if we're
doing that to one well and we want to
freeze that as one ampule we volume
reduce it just by aspirating the media
after the clumps of cells have settled
so we volume reduce it to a half a mil
we add a 2x freeze media which we make
in our own lab but you can use any
commercially available to X formulation
and then we just freeze it like that so
if people are interested I think in my
bio I'm not sure if my publications are
listed
but if they look up my name it's Cohen
RI I think it's a 2015 publication about
freezing tell if some great questions
coming in here's one how much time do I
have to plan for the whole experimental
procedure from ipsc generation up to
mature functional cells for example into
cardiomyocytes so typically the time
window to make passable IPS cells using
an episomal vector is around 30 days and
that doesn't always include the
generation of primary fiberglass so for
example if you bought an ampule a
fiberglass from vendor we've used
lifeline cell technologies they have a
media system that's really robust their
products are great you buy that and get
it in we can start doing the
transactions within a week and then with
all the time points needed I said with
within 21 days you can start to see
pretty early cells and then you know
colonies form and then really you need
three to four passages so typically
that's another 30 days or another four
weeks to amplify yourself so that's two
months and then cardiomyocyte the 14-day
protocol just another two weeks so
probably three months from start to
finish dr. Cohen do you freeze
cardiovascular progenitors I would like
to say yes but as I I sent of the
presentation we're able to make meds of
dermal cells we're not able to create a
stable cardiovascular progenitor cell
cultures just yet so we could pass his
own to time then they start to die on
mass and so we know we're missing
something do you think hypoxia is
important at every stage of
differentiation
no and that's why when you get to
cardiomyocytes we may have to modify the
level i think for neurons i think we can
keep it at low i'm not sure if you need
as low as four percent you may want to
go to six but i wouldn't go any higher
than that dr. Colin does the chir ninety
90 21 concentration differ between
different IPS cell lines yes and they
differ between embryonic stem cell lines
too so generally when we pioneer
protocol will take one cell line and
we'll use several different
concentrations of thi are and what we
see with high concentration and that's
six micromolar when we're making
cardiomyocyte is we see more clumps when
we use low and that's about 2 micro
molar we see more sheep so rather than
clumps the cells form like a muscular
sheet and then we decide how we want to
proceed with that cell line it doesn't
mean that those concentrations will work
exactly the same for every cell line we
have had so many great questions coming
in but we are running out of time this
is going to have to be our last question
start to Cohen how to generate ipscs
from LCL lymphoblastoid cell lines you
can use episomal vectors for that I know
their specific protocol to activate
blood related cells prior to the
transection I'm not quite familiar there
is someone at Rutgers that does that
they happen to use activated t-cells and
then they use Tendai virus but you can
use an episomal vector dr. Cohen thank
you so much for this great Q&A session
and you're very informative presentation
do you have any final comments for our
audience if you have my contact
information and if you have more
questions you're welcome to send
via email the plasmid that we're working
on we're making commercially available
through a related company and we'd be
happy to share that with people who are
interested in trying it thank you once
again dr. Rick Cohen and a big thank you
to our sponsor eppendorf for making
today's broadcast possible now before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's broadcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May
seventeenth 2017 you will receive an
email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
and we thank you for joining us hope to
see you again soon goodbye